you know why I love hip-hop the most
because people people that are really in
it they work like I'm in corporate
America I'm in Silicon Valley actually
that's why I fell in love with Silicon
Valley those nerds they worked like my
hip-hop friends did I'm like wait a
minute these kids are coding at 2:00 in
the morning right like going in the
studio last night in Midtown at 12:00
and watching everybody work they beast
work he's working they're working I was
the bird last night oh you see he was on
the show with you right yeah like like
and you know why it it motivates me
because in corporate America when I go
sit with CMOS and CEOs of Fortune 500
companies they don't work like this
they're done at 6 that's interesting
though because you have the type of
money that most rappers will probably be
like you know what I'm a relaxed hip-hop
guys work so hard because that's
probably their only opportunity you have
to make anything like really really make
them the ones that are about like
corporate America people are like that
other people like that this is not a
race or a genre thing most people want
to get to a certain place and they work
to be able to enjoy and relax there's a
small group that works for the [ __ ]
game I work with a game yeah I want
all-time legacy I want somebody I want
people watching this in 20:59 what's up
Jeremiah
that's my great-great grandson you know
like like that's that's what I want I
want all-time legacy I that's what I
want the reason by the way the reason
I'm nice and giving away all my best
content on Instagram and stuff it's not
because I'm Mother Teresa it's because I
want the leverage of being that guy what
do you think people should do